vote
vote vote we've been voting for decades
nothing meaningful has been accomplished
how has the experience of being black in
america changed
i lived black history amend the fight
for america is a performance documentary
that examines the revolutions and
counter-revolutions that have shaped
america
i remember when kennedy was shot i
remember when
martin luther king was shot we grew up
with the panthers
things have changed so much every day i
have conversations with my children
about the
current events things that are going on
today comparing them to
years ago
yes and they would but it was always a
white-washed version of history like oh
racism ended when the civil rights
movement was
i was taught the bare minimum everyone
learns about martin luther king
i honestly wish i learned a little bit
more about slavery today i'm looking
forward to being understood
a lot of the experiences that i have
with older black people is
i'm the parent you're the child you
don't have an opinion in my day
we had a consensus we knew exactly what
the priority was
today's youth they have a lot of mixed
messages so
i'm looking to hear what message is it
that they are trying to get across
[Music]
my name is beverly arrington tomorrow's
my birthday i'll be 70 years old
i have three children seven
grandchildren and three beautiful
great-grandchildren you look amazing
thank you so much
my name is skip townsend 57 years old
born and raised right here in los
angeles i'm the father of 12 children
i have 15 grandchildren i have one
great grandbaby i'm a advocate for peace
so i'm a domestic violence counselor
anger management parenting
i'm cynthia singleton i'm 74 years old
my main thing in retirement is i'm a
coordinator for intergenerational
tutoring program for lausd
and i'm happy i'm i'm really fortunate i
have a good life
hi i'm alex alexandra i'm 17 i'm a high
school student
i'm biracial so it's kind of hard for me
to find my
part of society so i fight for literally
everybody because i understand that we
are
extremely marginalized and we deserve
better
my name is devin hayden i'm 17 years old
when i go to college i hope to pursue a
degree in political science because i
feel as though there are not enough
young people
or black people in government hello i'm
bree
i'm in school i go to fitm and i'm
studying merchandising and marketing
i also work at a bakery just getting me
through college so yeah i'm just taking
life one day at a time i'm just trying
to figure out my my space in this world
can i get my grandparents on the right
and my team is on the left
if you agree step forward if you
disagree
stay back my generation has had it
harder than the other side
my first job was at a bank they would
use me as the supervisor but i was still
making minimum wage
and then they promoted all of these
other people
who were white i didn't have any of the
titles and did all the work
i was trusted to do the work i wasn't
trusted to get paid any more money
i had a job and they actually told me
that i looked too militant because i had
a throw
and i was proud of my throat and i had
an afro sticker on my car
and they told me in order to continue to
work here you have to
get rid of the fro and get the afro
sticker off of your car
we had to tow the line and look the best
act the best in order to have any kind
of advancement whereas now i think
there's
things are a little looser for me i
think being
14 15 years younger than youtube my
challenges were different it wasn't
about a job
we couldn't go to the movies because the
crips had started because now we can't
go to the park
now when i go to school there's a
different element so when my mother
tells me to go to the store and the
store is maybe two blocks away
but i know just crossing that busy
street puts me in in danger
it'll make me go six seven blocks the
other way and
my whole world was not about get a high
school diploma i just want to get home
every night
so it's just so many things that were
dangerous in my growing up in the 1980s
and 90s
that i think that what the children have
today is a
silver or maybe if he's a golden spoon
bring the golden spoon in here
yeah i completely agree with everything
i said and we could even say that we've
had a golden spoon in our mouth
you guys aren't wrong with that i mean
you guys definitely like paved the way
for us so we're just
following your footsteps almost i do
think that our generation has a lot of
pressure
on our career and education and i
appreciate it it is very stressful
and parents want me to have a good job
and go to a good school my grandparents
went the same but it's because
they want me to have what they didn't
have i wholeheartedly agree that you
guys had it way harder but
you guys were lucky in the point that
you knew who the racists were you knew
the kkk was down the street over there
you knew because they was in your face
with it now in the face of technology in
the new age
people are way covert about it they hide
it i've had somebody comment monkey
under my thing and i didn't even know
who it was i'm only 17 i'm not prepared
to have somebody on the internet who
doesn't know who i
am call me derogatory slurs or
you know threaten to kill me you know
what it's like to experience overt
racism
i don't but i need you guys in
situations like that because i don't
know what to do
i do have to say one thing that i kind
of disagree with
i feel as though the younger generation
doesn't have as much guidance or a
specific goal that you guys had you guys
had people like
malcolm x you guys have people like fred
hampton you've had people
like that who do we have obama maybe
we don't really have those leaders to to
guide us in a certain direction
i disagree i think you are the leaders
people are going to tell you that you
have to aspire to be somewhere but
martin luther king jr and malcolm x both
died before they were 40.
they were the leaders when they were
your age so
you guys are the leaders and who you
hang around see i hung around big
monster tiny killer little shooter baby
one punch
you guys are not hanging around them
you're hanging around people who are
inspired and motivated to do the same
things you're doing so
the leaders are here i don't think you
recognize them because they're right
next to you
protests should be peaceful absolutely
not
i've seen in the 1992 riots and also in
the recent
uprisings that a lot of opportunists
were there
and it was the opportunity to tear up
our own communities the emotions
the the drive the passion creates
something that turns violent it turns
ugly
and the rest of the world is able to see
that there's a lack of control let's
work on finding a solution
rather than just destroying the
community i think one of the greatest
examples
is the bus boycott the world runs on
economics
it's all about the money hurt them in
the wallet you can march to your blue in
the face but unless they're gonna lose
money then it doesn't affect them as
much as the bottom line does
that these people are gonna actually
stop buying our products
affect the money and i think you'll get
a much longer reaching effect
and you seem so peaceful
[Laughter]
i think when we were going through the
black lives matter protest
this past year you know the peaceful
protests were never seen
you know we would see a 10 second clip
of it and like oh there was a peaceful
protest an hour ago
although i don't agree with violence i
don't want anyone to get killed or hurt
i do think that
it brings a little bit more awareness to
what we're fighting for
i agree to an extent
i am a product of the watts riots we
lived at 115th and central
our friends were all in those riots
they'd knock on the door and tell my
mother hey miss addy
keep the kids inside things are getting
bad out here i don't agree with
everything that happened in the watts
riots because there was a lot of
destruction
but the watts riots are still referenced
today
my father always said the squeaky wheel
gets the oil but
i don't want anybody to be hurt i don't
want to see a repeat of what we saw at
the capitol
none of us want to see any kind of
nonsense like that we want to have a
message
with what you're doing yeah to some
extent i completely agree
but at the same time i'm a wholehearted
believer in civil disobedience for
example
the founding fathers though i am very
critical of them they used
violent tactics to get from britain to
be independents this is just property
damage i don't really
necessarily care if a building gets
burned down if a cop car gets burned
down because
how many people have been killed by the
hands of the police
and nothing has happened the whole
reason why people protest is because
they're upset about something
black people have every single right to
be upset
and i don't think that we would have got
the killers of george floyd convicted
had we been out there just holding the
sign
please convict no we need to apply
pressure to the government
because if they think that we're not
going to step up and take action and
hold them accountable
they're not going to do anything okay i
might interject a thought since i'm the
senior here
believe this if you believe nothing else
what you do now
will follow you for the rest of your
life this world is digitized and you
don't want to get in this man's system
because this brother can testify once he
gets you in that system
he will keep his foot on your neck and
you will never
ever hardly get free say you do
something by you get arrested
how's that arrest record going to affect
you for the rest of your life
i want people to think of long range i
think the black lives matter what made
me overjoyed and i had tears
because they got it these kids finally
got it vote vote vote protest yes
but where's the power i definitely think
that you should be voting but we have to
recognize how undemocratic our system is
we've been voting for decades nothing
meaningful has been
accomplished there are still disparities
when it comes to education there are
still disparities when it comes to
police brutality there are still
disparities when it comes to
drug charges these are all problems and
we've been
voting and it hasn't been working okay i
hear you
and i understand you but you have to
work within the system you live in
the system you live in is voting and as
you can see
biden and harris are in office voting
put them there
think about what you're doing who it's
affecting
and in the long range it's not just that
one day is what's the far-reaching
effect of this
what's the misconception people might
have about you
as a grandmother i think most people
think that i'm mean
i know some of the girls where i work
but say she's mean but boy she'll get
you out of trouble with the union
i'm very straightforward and i'm very
blunt i've always been because i grew up
in a family that was very structured
it was a very religious family and my
parents believed in corporal punishment
and i'm glad
because it's helped me a great deal in
my adult life i think it was a good
thing hard when you're young
you don't understand it but in the long
run
i think it's a good thing i
have dated people of another race
i couldn't get past a couple of dates
because we went to alvarez street
and lo and behold we ran into all these
brothers and i just felt so
uncomfortable
it's not the same for you as it does for
us a long time ago these were in the 60s
i just couldn't continue and when i told
him
i felt bad because he said you're a
racist you won't date me because of my
skin color and i thought about it and i
said yeah
that's deep i've always felt bad about
that
but i just couldn't do it
um i mean i'm in a relationship right
now with a white person
if you like you like like that that's it
shouldn't be can i ask you something
yeah of course
when you go out and you see brothers
african-american men
do they look at you different because
you're with a white guy a thousand
percent like i told them people are
going to look at us and
they're not looking at you they're
looking at me because i'm with you it
doesn't make me uncomfortable but i do
see people staring i think even though
i'm not against
interracial dating i think that if the
child
is black that they should never lose
that black culture
and try to assimilate another culture i
have a problem and an issue with that
so i'm obviously a product of
interracial relationship my mom is
filipino my dad is black
watching my parents try to understand
each other and then me being a biracial
person like
it's really hard to bridge that gap
because my mom is an immigrant from the
philippines she
doesn't know what the black experience
is i see the
disparity and understanding and in the
same sense that my dad doesn't really
understand what i go through and i'm in
a relationship with a black person right
now
and it's so much simpler to explain like
this is my experience as a black woman
this is what you will have to deal with
police brutality
if my child is dark skinned but until
this point i've never encountered anyone
that is willing to sit down with me and
be like okay
your experience is valid we're gonna get
through it together because they
completely shut down when they realize
you have baggage
in eighth grade i gave a speech to about
five thousand people i was for the
promotion from eighth grade to ninth
grade
and they were always telling me oh i'm
so articulate
and i don't like that very much because
i'm like well what does that mean you
know
sometimes i act white
when someone says you act white that's
not a thing that doesn't exist
it's more like a colloquial term that
people use to refer
to one power when people refer to me as
like oh yeah you talk whites you sound
white you dress white they're referring
to
a higher status than than my color my
skin color
ain't nobody gonna take me seriously if
i spoke like this if i went to a
a meeting and i spoke with like the
little twang in your voice
they gonna think oh you one of them you
wanted them ghetto ones you you'd allow
angry black women so i have to present
myself in a way
that is consumable and acceptable to the
people that i am presenting myself with
do you think that you being makes us
anything to do with that
oh yeah asian people have this positive
stereotype that they're the model
model minority myth like you're the
smart you're the good minority and
if people see me as that asian self and
i distance myself from
the blackness which i've had to do
before in order to give myself good
opportunities
it's unfair
it doesn't apply to me
my mother used to always tell me that i
act black
i had a hard time trying to get to the
other side of that and i don't think i
ever reached it i don't think i ever
acted white
maybe i should have said agree i do act
professional in certain settings like i
work in customer service i have to raise
my voice three octaves for people to
think that i'm being respectful and
maybe people think i'm white over the
phone maybe my name
and my voice correlates i could be white
but i never try
to be white um i think that i've heard
the term
you're one of those educated black women
i love being professional i love my
education to shine
love it can move in the other direction
if made to do so
i can go south real quick okay
i think that people mis mistake being
articulate
and educated for trying to be
white but i think our generation
that was the norm you strived every day
to be intelligent correct
i'm gonna be blunt you don't go out ashy
put that vaseline on your legs
on your elbows don't go out with rollers
in your hair are you crazy
we were taught you have to be better you
have to look better you have to act
better you have to dress better
you represent a whole group of people
and i think that
ideology may be lost a little now when
you go out
but we were trained to act the best we
could act
not to use ebonics you know we had to to
survive
i don't look at it as a negative thing
james bond once said that
whiteness is a metaphor for power black
people are trying to
get educated trying to seek intelligence
and knowledge to gain
power in one way or another whether it
be economic power whether it be
culturally
we want to be recognized as human beings
yes
all right i will say
the most impactful event for me was
being incarcerated in l.a county jail
in 1998. i was wrongfully accused and
treated unfairly in particular because
my father passed away
while i was about to start a trial for
two life sentences
and the reward that i got from my father
passing away is i was put in a hole the
system didn't know what to do with me so
they
put me in isolation it was done to
protect the other inmates because i
might have been volatile and
going through something would exploded
and
that's definitely unfair i think that
the system needs to
integrate some healthier procedures
i have trauma
um i would just say have a lot of trauma
with the cops my dad always had run-ins
i was always in the car from a young age
and i just get immense anxiety like
passing a cop car
seeing a cop when i first started
driving my parents hadn't even put like
my registration
everything like right above my head so i
didn't have to reach so i wouldn't get
shot
when i get pulled over i facetime my
father i have video like
it's stressful to be afraid of a cop
on a daily basis but that's what i got
to go through i
watch black people die on tv like it's a
show
for everyone to see i watched george
floyd die
in front of the entire world in my phone
that looked like my father to me
when i saw brianna taylor i thought of
my sister when i saw mod aubry i saw my
older brothers
it takes a toll on you to see that and
to constantly understand that this is
your reality this could
potentially be me i've been
assaulted and experienced
microaggressions and have been harassed
before
and you know nobody really wants to talk
about it because what do you say
to like a 12 year old girl who's just
been you know
sexualized it's a painful conversation
that a lot of people
are not ready to have so acknowledging
everything you guys said
i want to talk about ptsd but not post
traumatic stress disorder i want to talk
about what you just said which is
present
it's happening right now i'm
consistently it's reoccurring trauma
i feel like i'm in a domestic violence
relationship with law enforcement
with society with the government and at
any moment my life and my children's
life are in danger
and you guys as well so it's not
post-traumatic
it's present it's right now
um that's one of the blessings of
growing old
you get control of your emotions more
so i don't think i'm as stressed as a
lot of people over the things that are
happening
they affect me but i know that i can't
control it so what is that going to cost
me in the long run
if i lose myself and my health and
everybody doesn't have that
luxury to be able to do that and i
understand that
and because i think two things happened
to me when i was very a younger woman in
my 20 in my
30s 40s my son was shot and killed
on the street and drive-by shooting and
two years later
my husband committed suicide so
you get so you realize you can't control
everything
but you can control how you react to it
and you've got to get yourself under
control
or um you will lose yourself
so i guess in a way i have tpa what do
you call it ptsd
ptsd yeah so i seem very composed i seem
very cool
it's because you have to be to survive
you have to
it's all about surviving
generational trauma is real that's it
post slavery trauma
went into my grandparents who taught my
mother
and my mother taught me it's really
important to know that
it has been passed on my mother beat me
because her mother beat her
yes her mother beat her because her
mother beat her
yes because they did not want the
masters on the plantations
to beat their children so they said no
no begging please no
i'm gonna teach them and they get a whip
and go beat their own kids so that
someone else wouldn't
and this is passed down this is handed
down to me
even where you know i said i have 12
children well seven of the oldest ones
they too got beatens where the last five
they got talking to they got time out so
we go sit on the porch
it's a different concept and it is
definitely handed down yeah so it goes
back
all the way to slavery i would take it
back to that's crazy
pre-slavery adding on to what you say
that's kind of why a lot of
stress-induced illnesses
it runs in black families is because
we're constantly under this pressure and
stress
mental health isn't something that black
people can afford to deal with because
you have a whole bunch of other issues
to deal with in a day-to-day life
you can't afford to go see a therapist
because you got to get them bills paid
right and i just want to say that we
were told
you will deal with things that you've
never dealt with before so you're going
to have to
you know find your way and just dealt
with it maybe very privately
or go to church and listen to the
sermons you know and let the pastor tell
us
you know what's all this stuff that's
going on yes a lot of people went to
church and dealt with stuff other people
went outside the liquor store
so mad dog 2020 cisco
saint ives old english became the
healing they dealt with it through
alcohol or substance abuse living in the
united states
is a privilege
[Applause]
i mean yes there's million flaws in our
system but i do have all these resources
and programs
some kids don't even get to read have a
book have a pencil so i'm just unlucky
to be here that's all yeah i have been
fortunate enough
i've traveled all over the world vietnam
singapore japan
china italy rome france and there's no
place
like the united states because
we have a middle class almost everywhere
in the world it's rich or poor
there's no section 8 there's no wick
there's no afdc
you dis on your ass
i've been to other countries as well and
it really matters what you value like
when i go to places like the philippines
yes they're poor over there but their
family bonds are like this they are
happy
who do you see who's working a
nine-to-five job behind a desk happy
with what they live with
people in the suburbs doing the same
thing every day for 40 years
just having kids staying home going to
work
and i feel like the perception that you
guys carry isn't as a result
of the indoctrination of the american
dream you're taught that you're going to
get a white pick a fence with a nice
house in the suburbs and that's why so
many people come here is because
we sell america like this is a utopia a
great place but then you come here and
then you see immigrants suffering so
they come here expecting better only to
have a different set of struggles
i understand how you feel
but it's one thing to say it than to
live it
and even yourself like when you go to
the philippines i've been the
philippines they were exploited from the
military base that was there
i mean they live in deplorable
conditions universal health care
yeah that's all good too but look at
some of the other conditions they live
in
we take for a lot for granted i just
still say it's it's not as easy as it
looks
um do you think that america has been
good or do you think black people have
been privileged in america
for me it's a compare and contrast this
is good about this country this is bad
about america this is bad about this
country this is good about america
and for me i i feel you know i like it
here
you know so i want to answer your
question
that's what's good about traveling black
people are
prejudice against all over the world
it's not just in america
because the ruling class has made you
think that blonde hair blue eyes and
light skin is better
true so in brazil if you're light
skinned you're better
in africa women are dying of cancer to
bleach their skin white
so don't think it's just america that
suppresses the black man
i'd be hard put for me to leave the
united states and be able to survive at
the level i live here
very good point uh you know michael that
this side of the room
the um bad hips the bullet wounds and
all that starting to set in for this
side
just let you know all right
black people are resilient wow
softball question i am a strong black
woman
and i would not be here today if i
wasn't i
am a strong black woman as well
because i am willing to take on
anything that affects my family
affects the things that i believe in i'm
a strong black man
and i know that because of all the
obstacles and challenges that i had to
face
not only with society but i had to face
the challenges within my own community
i'm resilient because i have the power
to harm or to heal
and at this time i choose to heal i'm
resilient power to you
my great-grandmother was a slave so it
taught my grandfather how to be
resilient how my mom
and me so we've been taught since we
were born like how to be resilient
it's a powerful trait to have i'll say
that's true
every obstacle all the turmoil we've had
to overcome
it's amazing that we're all sitting here
right now us as a people
are one of the most resilient people
that have walked this earth
we've been beaten down we've been
assaulted we've been tore down in ways
i don't even think humanity could even
comprehend
and yet we still get up every single
time i'm still
gonna sit here for hours and listen to
you guys tell your story so that my
son or daughter won't have to go through
that again i want it to end here we all
deserve better
well i want to say that i apologize to
you guys because
i was expecting uh i was expecting y'all
to be sagging
i was expecting you to be combing your
hair you're hitting on your phone
and stuff so i apologize because i had a
misconception but i had no idea who you
were going to be
and you guys really are the leaders so
i'm
i'm honored and humbled to be in your
present today
thank you guys for being here because
you put something in me
[Music]
so
you